The Android griddle plug in creates
a set of configurations for
each build variant.
This allows us to manage dependencies
independently for each of our variants.
So we'll have the usual compile and
run time configurations.
But we'll also have free compile and
free runtime.
And so on.
The free runtime configuration extends
the free compile configuration.
Just as compile extends runtime
when using the Java plugin.
Additionally, free compile configuration
extends the regular compile
configuration.
Which means our free variance will
include all of our default dependencies.
In addition to those added
to the free configurations.
It's probably likely that we would
want to enable ads in the free version
of our app, but not in the paid.
Utilizing Google's Ad Services requires
to depend on the Ad Services Library.
However we don't want to unnecessarily
bloat the paid version of our app
by including a library
that won't be needed.
To solve this problem we can simply
declare this dependency only for
the free version of our app.
As you can see here,
we've added a dependency to
the Google Play ad services.
But we've assigned it to
the free compile configuration.
That's really there is to declaring
variant specific dependencies.
But we've included a demo
in the course repository.
You should check it out.